Welcome back.
>> So, Nosmo, what happened to your neck?
>> Oh, I hurt it. I actually have slightly limited range of motion
and so I can only move this way, kind of like a robot.
>> Oh, no.
>> Kind of like an alive Android.
>> Sounds like you have a constraint.
>> I know, it, it is a constraint, but instead of
fighting against it, I'm going to totally embrace it and work with
it. Well actually this lesson is all about how to work within
constraints and deliver great user experiences.
So you're actually right at home.
>> I know. That's awesome. Let's get started. So in lesson
two we taught you some tools called personas in use cases that
allow you to better prioritize your future lists and make really
good applications. And you also learned a little bit about UX research.
>> And in lesson one, we taught you about hi, low-res
wire framing. Which helps you think about the big picture first, before
you go into things like flows and details and UI elements.
So, Nosmo, let's talk about what you're going to learn in lesson three.
>> Okay.
>> In this lesson you'll learn how to design for
the Mobile user. And how this is different from designing for
a web or a desktop user. You'll also learn about
four mobile constraints that you'll need to keep in mind for
any mobile apps that you'll build. Then you'll learn more
about wire framing and picking up from where we left off
in lesson one. We're going to go deeper into how to design
a flow of screens to support each step inside your application.